the snowman was directed by Tomas
Alfredson the man behind Tinker Tailor
Soldier Spy and let the right one in it
was executive produced by Martin
Scorsese starring Michael Fassbender and
Rebecca Ferguson as well as JK Simmons
based off of a best-selling novel there
is no reason for this movie to not be at
least good it's about two detectives who
are on the trail of a killer who builds
snowmen at all of his victims he also
sends cryptic notes to the police as
well taunting them Michael Fassbender
plays detective harry hole i was excited
for this film because of the talent in
front of and behind the camera it looked
very much so like a wintertime zodiac
and i'm a big fan of zodiac this is a
monumentally disappointing movie it's a
gigantic beautiful looking mess it has
amazing cinematography incredible talent
everywhere you look and a story that is
so horrific ly convoluted I struggle to
comprehend how this film made the final
cut how its released there is so much
more editing work to be done here entire
scenes need to be inserted into this
movie for it to make sense in fact I
just read an interview with the director
himself where he stated that 10 to 15%
of the script was not even filmed he
openly admitted to the fact that there
are specific puzzle pieces integral to
this movie and for the audience to grasp
it fully that were never even filmed I
would say for the first half of this
movie I was semi invested because I kept
saying to myself it's going to start
soon this is just the setup it's getting
me interested in the characters it's
creating intrigue there are answers
coming I will understand everything and
a lot of these random character choices
and scenes and subplots will eventually
amount to something then the film ended
and I realized that none of that was
true
this film builds and builds and builds
to nothing the entire film feels like a
setup in fact there's a scene towards
the end that is trying to get us excited
for a sequel I guess they were just
making a feature-length trailer for a
potential sequel because
that's what this film feels like it
never builds to really anything of Merit
it's such a gorgeously shot movie and
very respectably acted phos bender and
ferguson in particular are really great
here they are doing a lot with very
little you never really get inside our
lead characters head
you don't understand really why he
changed smokes or why he's such a
drunkard why he wakes up in parks
sleeping on benches if that was
mentioned in the film where there was a
hint to it I must have missed it I did
not get up to go to the bathroom I was
laser focused on this movie I don't know
what his character is I don't understand
his backstory he seems to have some pain
in regards to his former relationship
with Charlotte Gainsbourg character but
beyond that you really never get inside
his head Rebecca Ferguson also remains a
bit of a mystery and her backstory is
eventually revealed through flashbacks
that feel very ham-fisted and almost
filmed at the last minute Tomas
Alfredson is a director who really
understands how to photograph beautiful
scenery he knows how to make a
good-looking movie but demonstrated by
the finale of this film he has a lot to
learn when it comes to action sequences
there is a confrontation that occurs in
the last 10 minutes or so that feels
like it was filmed entirely and then
edited to obtain a pg-13 rating the
mystery here is that this movie is rated
R so this entire end confrontation has
integral moments that are just missing
things happen and I actually set in my
head what the hell does what how did
that happen it looks as if it was reshot
with stunt doubles or they just didn't
know how to film an action sequence
because the entire finale of this movie
the lady sitting next to me whispered
under her breath what a dumbass and
normally I'm annoyed when people talk
out loud but I couldn't help but think
that about the lead character he makes
this Troy it's just it just kind of it
the whole movie just deflates in the
final minutes this is a beautiful
looking movie extremely well acted
respectably
presented but the story builds to
nothing
it features characters that make choices
that also build to nothin JK Simmons
character is a complete mystery his
purpose in this movie sure you can
explain it it can be explained why he's
in the film but beyond the idea of let's
have multiple characters because it's a
whodunit his character and his associate
have the most random reasons for being
in this movie there's an entire sequence
and subplot devoted to whether or not
where they live is going to be the host
of the next World Cup there's more set
up for this device the detectives used
to film their subjects that they
interview than the lead characters in
this movie it's a monumental
disappointment and I'm gonna give the
Snowman a d-plus this film had every
opportunity to be great but beyond being
a really good-looking movie with
respectable performances they basically
dropped the ball at every corner but I
do want to make sure you guys know that
I am running my promotion with audible
if you go to audible.com slash Kris you
can start a free 30-day trial audible
makes getting more books in your life
easy they have an unbeatable selection
of audiobooks with incredible
performances from celebrities you can
transform any long commute that you're
taking and ride with audible and listen
to audiobooks on the go and the
audiobook for the novel the Snowman
which I just reviewed the feature film
adaptation of is available on audible if
you go to audible.com slash Kris you can
have that free 30-day trial thank you so
much to audible for continuing to
sponsor my videos and thank you guys for
watching as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]